shooting in Nashville
six dead three kids three adults rallies
marches demands for gun safety
Republicans saying armed the teachers
and put armed guards in school but
meanwhile in this week how many mass
shootings have there been how many mass
shootings have there been just in the
last week because yesterday there was
one in Baltimore and I'm looking at my
list here and of course it's very hard
to keep up because there are so many
yesterday a mass shooting in Baltimore
and then also one in Mesa Arizona
and there was a mass shooting yesterday
in Hampton Virginia another one on
Sunday in Petersburg Virginia the point
is just in the intervening time between
the Nashville shooting and today and we
follow all of the lives affected
everything that's taken place all of the
discourse and discourse may be a bit of
a generous term in some of these cases
we follow all of it
there have been so many mass shootings
since